Перекриті траси. Мітинги біля облгазів та міськрад.
Уже кілька місяців Полтавщина гуде, як розлючений бджолиний рій.
Та жах! Усе людей доять та доять, як би ще шкури з нас поспускали!
Це взаконені бандюки, їх взаконили влада наша!
Люди обурені агресивною політикою газовиків, які через несплачені платіжки відключили понад сотню домогосподарств від газу.
А також занепокоєні зростанням тарифів на газ, які поволі зростали торік, а з січня взагалі підвищилися одразу на 30 відсотків.
Мітинги не припинилися навіть після того, як уряд на тлі протестів знизив тариф на цей опалювальний сезон
з майже 9-ти до приблизно 7-ми гривень за кубометр газу.
Бо для багатьох мешканців Лубенського району на Полтавщині платіжки за газ все одно залишилися непосильним фінансовим тягарем.
У мене пенсія 2800. У мене не вистачає. Додала, в дітей взяла 500 грв, щоб мені заплатити за комуналку! А як же мені жити!
За трубу прийшло 3400, за газ нагорить тисячу з чимось. А в мене 2200 пенсія.
Сидимо без хліба, без нічого. А платити - вчасно платимо!  Дуже дорого для пенсіонерів.
На таку пенсію можна загортатися в простирадло і чекати смерті.
Газ виключили. Холодна хата. Приходимо, дровами топимо, от і все.
Одягнутий спиш, ходиш одягнутий у хаті. Оце такий газ.
До тотальної економії тепер вдаються не лише пенсіонери. Над багатьма будинками - ось такий дим.
Люди повідключали газові котли і почали опалювати дровами.
Треба таскати і таскати. Я вже спину зірвав, спина болить!
Якщо сильні морози, то доводиться через кожні дві години приїжджати і підкидати дрова.
Як проґавиш, то доведеться знову розпалювати.
Тепло в оселі мешканця Лубен Миколи Ащаулова повністю залежить від цього саморобного каміну.
Від газопостачання його відключили ще в грудні. Це при тому, що за спожитий газ він регулярно сплачував.
Але з минулого року в Україні запровадили нові правила розрахунків. Платежі за газ розділили на два.
Окремо треба платити компанії-постачальнику за спожитий газ.
Окремо - газорозподільчій компанії за транспортування газу від магістралі до оселі.
І якщо споживач невчасно надає показники споживання газу, як це сталося у випадку Миколи,
газорозподільча компанія сама нараховує платіж, суму якого вираховує із середнього обсягу споживання не за поточний рік, а за минулий.
Якщо не вчасно, включають програму, і вона рахує. А рахує вона по тому року, коли було більше спожито газу.
І ніхто не хоче балакати . Я їм 700 гривень платив до цього. Зараз тут 3500.
Кажу, мовляв, добре, давайте перерахуємо. І по факту сплачу. Ні! Ми не будемо рахувати. Ви заборгували! Платіть!
Нині Микола - активний учасник усіх акцій протесту.
У Лубнах об'єдналася ініціативна група з тих, кого відключили від газу, та місцевих громадських захисників прав споживачів,
які хочуть захистити громадян, як вони стверджують, від "агресивних дій" місцевого підприємства "Лубнигаз".
Ініціативна група вже зібрала понад 100 скарг про відключення газу через борги за його розподіл.
Серед них - і ті, хто взагалі не отримував квитанції за розподіл, і ті, хто неправильно зрозумів методику нарахування, сплативши менше,
і навіть ті, хто взагалі відмовився від газопостачання, думаючи, що йому не доведеться платити за розподіл газу.
Ми живимося з Яблунівського родовища. Це за 40 км від нас знаходиться. І ми користуємося цим газом.
А ми сплачуємо, як нібито наш газ побіг кудись в Іркутськ чи в Тюмень, збігав до Європи і знову прибіг до нас у Лубни. Ну так виходить!
Через Амстердам! Десь бігав-бігав… Бо така в нас ціна. У нас є свій видобуток і в нас - найдорожчий газ!
"Лубнигаз" каже, що не має повноважень самостійно змінювати тарифи,
оскільки це робить Національна комісія з рулювання у сферах енергетики та комунальних послуг.
Крім того, в "Лубнигазі" заявляють, що Полтавщина навіть, якщо буде з усіх сил економити споживання газу,
все одно перебуватиме в "заручниках" високих тарифів за розподіл газу.
У тому й проблема, що населення стає менше, але менше стає і великих промислових підприємств, які є великими споживачами газу.
І обсяг розподілу зменшується, відповідно оплата збільшується.
Таким чином побудована методика розрахунку оплати розподілу природного газу, і це закріплено законодавчо.
Юристка громадського комітету із захисту прав споживачів два останні місяці вивчає газове законодавство
і зізнається, що перебуває в певному шоці від подібних методик нарахувань.
Вона називає "дискримінацією" ситуацію, коли тариф за розподіл у маленьких селищах та містах більший, ніж у великих.
Приміром, у Лубнах за це платять у вісім разів більше, ніж у Києві.
У Києві 31 копійка за розподіл, а в Лубнах - 2,45.
Оскільки тут велика кількість труб, а населення мало, то протяжність труб ділять калькулятором на кількість населення і встановлюють 2,45 за розподіл.
Це повністю порушує права людини. Як це? Залежно від проживання встановлювати різну плату за розподіл за товар?
Юристка нарікає також на те, що облгази часто блокують наміри споживачів обрати собі іншого газопостачальника, в якого ціни, приміром, менші.
Як, приміром, у випадку Юлії Назаренко.
Вона вже третє намагається змінити газопостачальника.
Коли вона вперше робила заявку на підключення до послуг "Нафтогазу", "Лубнигаз" без попередження просто відімкнув її від газопостачання.
Я приїхала до них, вони почали запитувати, чому ми переходимо до іншого постачальника.
На що я відповіла, що в Україні є ринок газу і ми маємо на це вільне право.
Нам сказали, що в нас безліч недоліків: не пройдений техогляд, замуровані труби і в нас котел не відповідає документації.
Чому нам 11 років не було взагалі ніяких зауважень? Чому це сталося в той момент, коли ми вирішили змінити постачальника?
Виконувач обов’язків міністра енергетики Юрій Вітренко в інтерв’ю DW визнав, що така проблема існує.
Майже 70% облгазів належать олігарху Дмитру Фірташу.
Більшість з цих облгазів зловживають своїм домінуючим становищем, і їхні послуги завищені подекуди на 30%.
Юрій Вітренко вважає, що протистояти газовикам мають ОТГ.
Знайшли, наприклад, цікавий варіант рішення.
У кожної людини є дуже обмежена ринкова сила.
Ми розуміємо, що одній людині проти облгазу складно воювати.
Але для цього об’єднуються у громади.
Ми можемо дати можливість, щоб у ситуації, коли людина немає часу власноруч обирати постачальника,
за замовчанням це робила територіальна громада.
І тоді громада мала б достатню силу протистояти тому ж облгазу.
Однак у Лубенській ОТГ кажуть, що так лише в теорії.
На практиці ж цілій громаді повністю перейти до іншого газопостачальника майже нереально,
адже мешканці ОТГ мають різні міркування щодо того, кого з присутніх на ринку газових постачальників обрати.
Важелів впливу на газовиків в ОТГ замало.
Останнім часом "Лубнигаз" почав собі поводитися дуже нахабно по відношенню до населення.
Я скажу, що зухвалі дії стосуються спілкування співробітників "Лубнигазу" і стосується перш за все ще й порозуміння з населенням.
Але ми ситуацію виправляємо, тому що наприкінці минулого року була створена робоча група,
провели два засідання, на яких ми питання ставимо щодо поведінки та роботи "Лубнигазу".
Оскільки вона є приватною, то впливати ми можемо тільки таким чином.
Місцеві активісти готові до більш рішучих дій.
Вони подали заяву про відкриття провадження проти керівництва "Лубнигаз" щодо порушення кількох статей Кримінального кодексу.
Кримінальне впровадження буде відкрито - 364 -1 і 365-2.
Це дві статті, за які можливо притягнути до кримінальної відповідальності представників "Лубнигазу" -
повне перевищення службових повноважень, проникнення в приватну власність і все інше, що вони наробили.
Активісти також готують колективний позов до адміністративного суду,
який має дати оцінку і нарахованим платіжкам, і діям газовиків, які під час карантину вдалися до відключень,
хоча це заборонено на період коронавірусних обмежень законом від березня минулого року.
У "Лубнигазі" натомість стверджують, що мають право на безперешкодний доступ до осель, а правила карантину не порушували.
Відповідно до закону про тимчасові обмеження під час розповсюдження коронавірусної інфекції,
відключати заборонено за несплату або неповну сплату за комунальні послуги.
З приводу наших відключень шановних абонентів, то можу пояснити,
що всі відключення відбувалися виключно на підставі правил безпеки газопостачання і викликані лише їхнім порушенням.
Жодного відключення в період карантину за борги нашим підприємством не було здійснено.
Активісти в Лубнах не вірять таким заявам і вимагають від місцевої влади,
щоб ОТГ знайшло варіант, як перестати бути "заручником" у газовиків.
Приміром, створити власне комунальне підприємство з газорозподілу.
Для цього треба в суді оскаржити рішення попередніх керівників району про передачу газових мереж облгазу.
Але в ОТГ кажуть, що для цього необхідні відповідні рішення влади в Києві.
Власне, цього вимагає у президента Володимира Зеленського "Тарифний майдан".
Протестувальники хочуть, аби держава повернула громадам право розпоряджатися газовими мережами,
які колись будували за кошти держави, міст, районів, громад, споживачів, але з 2005 року поступово передавали олігархам.
Крім того, протестувальники вимагають, аби провели реформу Національної комісії,
що здійснює державне регулювання у сферах енергетики та комунальних послуг -
аби НКРЕКП встановлювала тарифи, узгоджуючи це з громадами, а не лише з облгазами.